she said so I feel like paying five
thousand dollars for a husband who's
vouched for meets my needs and is ready
for a real relationship is totally worth
it do you notice how she didn't say
anything she would bring she said he has
to meet my needs but what about you
meeting his needs but this is the thing
women will get to society has pulled us
chase the career be successful whatever
and she did that and she makes it to 35
years old never having once thought
about what men want and this is why the
red pill is so important because we go
through our whole lives never having
even heard what men want he also said
can't be his second wife lady like lady
like you're rolling out you're 35 years
old and you're going to rule out men
because they've been married before